Apple have you heard about these guys
it's apparently a big phone computer
company little guys that I think they're
gonna be doing okay uh there is a rumor
that they are thinking about buying
Tesla Tesla if you don't know they make
electric cars and components for
electric cars it's an American company
and their CEO Elon Musk met with Apple
executives and now the tech bloggers are
all freaking out thinking whoa is Apple
gonna start making the I car if you
don't know about the Tesla let's look at
a couple of them these are pretty fancy
think these things have been popping up
all over la have you guys been there
have you guys will see in them yeah
they're the DeLorean doors yeah that's
the DeLorean door right you've driven in
1 i've driven in 1 and how do you feel
they are amazing for some reason first
of all the picks up is a stack mm-hmm so
you step on the pedal and bam it's just
like you just don't like it's a rocket
or something yes their navigation stream
is screen is like as big as my
television which is nice because the
navigation screen I have in my Prius you
can't even read the names of the streets
this you can see the names of every it's
great i love a Tesla yeah okay so I'm
pretty sure we're all on board the idea
of the electric car right we're used to
go with that sustainable environmentally
friendly etc uh is this just the next
step for Apple like doesn't this just
seemed pretty obvious like they've
dominated everything that we have in our
pockets and now they're going to
dominate what we grabbin if Apple takes
over Tesla then there's one thing that
we can guarantee that if it's not
already Tesla will become a super shitty
product that will be super way more
expensive than it already is and if
anything breaks on it you have to
replace the whole car yeah that's that's
what I can guarantee you about Tesla
being owned by and we're gonna have to
take our Tesla's into that genius bar
with your smug 18 year old baby made in
China anyway I get the idea that that my
car is the manufacturing of my cars
making someone want to commit suicide
don't as in that it's a good feeling
inside like a somebody's really had a
shitty time putting this together right
but it'll continue to be designed in
cupertino oh that's what they always say
in the Apple commercials rat designed in
cupertino they somehow don't mention
made in China no and that's the only as
as though all of the exotic locales in
the entire world that I would want to
know the weather on my phone the only
one that comes with is cupertino which
I had to find on a map when I got an
apple phone right because they want you
to think that's like Mecca or Jerusalem
or something like that eight in
cupertino I don't wanna brag a beautiful
downtown Cupertino I have stayed in
beautiful downtown Cupertino at the I
forget the name of the or the grandview
in did you drive your Tesla there I wish
I drove my Tesla that I drove my Prius
there by Priya so you're halfway there
right just to give you a little sense of
the numbers Tesla is worth twenty four
billion dollars Apple's worth yes small
paltry 485 billion so yes they could
easily afford to make this thing happen
but let's get away from that the
specifics of that a little bit just
electric cars why haven't they picked up
is this just 101 you know the car lobby
keeping the electric people dead cat
t-rex's and stegosauruses are sitting
around and saying we have to protect
this fossil fuel and they're smoking
their stogies and they don't want that
to happen yeah so it's just standard
money there's no doubt about it sure
there I mean look what they did to the
even American politicians will [ __ ] on
American cars look what they did to the
Chevy Volt right so or at least and the
but they came on there like all this is
they they really poo pooed it yeah and
even though was the car the year and all
that stuff and so it to the point where
didn't uh Chevy take it off the market
for a little while or they did some well
there were some recalls and then it's
back on now and and but it's a great guy
i mean the future obviously is electric
cars i think but you know all the oil in
the ground i mean you have to understand
that the most powerful richest
corporations that the world has ever
known owned that Oil not gonna leave it
there so it comin out your kid right now
unlike the cigarette thing that we just
did where they may be were doing it out
of goodness of their hearts you're
thinking that the oil people we're not
gonna do it like that that's coming out
so I really don't see and this whole
thing about our now we're getting
Steinem change the subject little bit
but they're saying now all we're gonna
get serious about climate change the
president's getting serious about it's
too late it's over climate change is
happening it's going to keep happening
and we need to put our energies into
living with climate change not trying to
stop interchange because it's a too late
I'll go out on your crazy tangent so uh
if Tesla is going to be bought by Apple
isn't this the type of thing that could
be about how do we live yet climate
change because if anyone can give us
products that will believe in and all
that it is a no-go Gina because Apple
kills people because the the the the
conditions in which the Apple products
are made are shitty and they're made in
third world countries and it's super
polluting and it sucks and nobody can
afford a Tesla and so nobody's going to
drive them and so none of this is going
to matter anyway it's all for PR and
it's all just for looks so it's easy to
crap on Apple but should we maybe give
them a little props that maybe this
could be good you're not aboard the
crazy train i think i don't i don't
think anyone who it would matter so you
could afford it yeah I I don't know what
do I know why you but I'll get a Tesla
mr. Rockefeller over here the chest by
the way it costs about 70,000 by they
started about 70 pounds oh yeah kicks up
of my dad the Great Grey Poupon windows
by the way you don't even get the button
windows with